hi my name is Kimberly strong and I'm
the primary faculty with the program in
genomics and ethics at the Medical
College of Wisconsin in the Center for
Bioethics and Medical Humanities I'm
going to be talking today perhaps from a
slightly different perspective than you
might be used to or you might be um it's
there anything through some of the other
presentations but I'm going to be
talking about the different perspectives
that people might be bringing to other
ways that they might be looking at
genome sequences to philly ethical
issues that keep discussed on quite
frequently and um so I'm going to be
hypothesizing in some ways that various
groups of people might be considering
this issue as I go along just a quick
reminder that should you have questions
that come up feel free to write those in
however I probably will leave them to
the end to sort of address some of those
a lot of the things that I'm going to be
discussing I'm hoping will generate some
discussion or some questions along the
way so I'm just going to tell you a
little bit about myself and there's some
reasons for that but I'll get to that in
a moment so I have a bachelor's degree
in biology of the minor in chemistry
that I gained here in the United States
actually and then after about a decade I
decided to go to grad school and did
that overseas in Australia so if I you
hear a slight accent that's that's
partly where that come from so I did a
qualifications in genetic counseling in
Newcastle Australia and did my PhD in
bioethics at the University of Sydney um
now some things I'm pointed out as well
is that I I've had experience with two
different types of health systems so a
public system that exists in the
Australian context and the private
system here in the United States
although there is a private system as
well
and in Australia kind of an additional
system the my professional background
includes some experience in genetics in
pre-implantation genetic diagnosis
embryology genetic counseling
psychosocial research matched unrelated
blood and marrow transplant in
particular this search and the patient
advocacy Pat perspectives in that arena
um policy development and bioethics of
course just primarily what I'll be
talking about today and in particular on
empirical bioethics which I'll talk a
little bit more about what empirical
bioethics is but it in very very short
empirical bioethics is using a pair
called kind of methods to explore
epically contentious or bioethical
issues some things that I'm not tonight
I always kind of put this out there's a
little bit of a disclaimer is that I'm
not overly tech-savvy so my knowledge of
genomics for instance and some of the
ways in which the technology is move
forward maybe beyond certain my
understanding of genetics that I gained
quite a long time ago I'm also not a
practicing clinician so while I have
qualifications in genetic counseling I'm
not seeming your patients and Families
anymore and not a violin from the titian
by any stretch of the imagination I also
don't claim to be a true philosopher so
I put that out as the disclaimer in case
there are any philosophers watching that
the moment I mean really the list goes
on because there's a reason when I talk
about that up front and that that I'm
going to be proposing some things as
some ways that groups of people might be
looking at the ethical issues and the
types of hopes on around genome
sequencing and it's based on some of
this previous experience that I have but
I would also suggest that anyone who's
coming to their research is going to
bring particular types of background
although I think being transparent about
it is
particularly important in various genres
of research I do qualitative research
for being reflected in this way is just
an absolute requirement but I wanted to
to put that out so that those of you
watching can kind of consider how those
backgrounds that I've just discussed
might be playing a role and might be
informing the types of things that I put
forward some things I wanted to
highlight at the beginning really should
have named my talk variables that may
impact the waiting is given to genome
sequencing issues we know at the moment
that data is limited really as to the
ways that people are weighing the risks
and the benefits around genome to
convene we certainly can draw from
experience that's been gained to genetic
testing of single gene disorders and in
other microarray testing but I think
when it comes to genome sequencing in
the vastness of that data we're not an
entirely certain how people are weighing
these things so I'm making some
suggestions around that and really my
aim is to to kind of generate some
discussion and possibly drive some areas
of research because we see a lot of
commentary coming out around the ethical
issues particularly around the return of
incidental findings of secondary
findings and concerned about privacy etc
I wanted to perhaps suggest that and and
encourage the types of research where we
interact with the people who are on the
front lines and making those decisions
so that the types of clinicians that are
on the front line as well as the types
of patients and families that may be
involved in the decision making so there
are many people that are talking through
this conference opportunity that would
have vast amount of information about
genome sequencing I put this slide in
simply for those that may be watching
only this broadcast and not others so
genome sequencing is really a process
that's used to do to look at once full
DNA compliment
so well we don't know what all of that
compliment means we are able to look at
the the various base pairs that are
basically the design for the bodies make
outfitting processes this genomic data
in speaking about the fact that it's
responsible for for the the workings of
the body are very comprehensive the
comprehensiveness aids really in the
types of questions that can be answered
but it can't actually answer all the
questions to play since we're still
learning about what that information may
mean but again with the positive comes
some of the negative that the fact that
this information is so comprehensive
magnifies some of the potential for
misuse or four areas of contention
around privacy and it challenges some of
our current paradigms around on the
identification etc so the the complexity
and the uncertainty around some of this
genomic data also means that there's the
possibility that the information could
be misunderstood that it can be seen as
more determinative than it is known to
be at this at this point in time and
that some of the multifactorial
applications or implications may be
downplayed in some ways we know that
this enormous amount of data generates
the likelihood of incidental findings or
findings that we weren't expecting or
findings that might be secondary to what
one was initially going in looking for
and that this issue even lead to strip
the information of the traditional types
of identifiers is that we would think
would provide a protective nature around
identifying research participants
ticularly eyes on some of this
information is placed on public
databases if
it's um requiring us to kind of rethink
or two to identify ways that that this
information might be unique because of
the fact that it is in itself perhaps
one of the most identifiable type of
features to the individual and it raises
those questions about who should have
access to the data and control that data
on because of this potential
identifiability so some of the uses of
genome sequencing it can be used in
various contexts I don't intend for this
to be all-inclusive but I am trying to
touch on the majority of the types of
uses um so it's been using their
research arena though when we talk about
the research arena on it does at times
raise some different types of concerns
around obligations to research
participants and whether or not um
there's going to be potential benefit
for the infant for the individual thats
saying yes to particular types of
research and if there is an expectation
of benefit how long does that
expectation last we know that we're
constantly learning more about the
genome and when there's new information
found does that require that researchers
go back and we examine that information
so some of these current paradigms that
were used to do require some additional
thinking from the clinical perspective
MCW has some experience around or
considerable experience around the the
issue of the clinical Odyssey or the
diagnostic Odyssey whereby if an
individual or family has been trying to
find out what the cause of particular
symptoms are and genome sequencing was
utilized in order to help guide that
diagnosis of course there are other
potential clinical uses around
personalized medicine a lot just
disgusting the realm of cancer genetics
cancer genomics the tumor what type of
genetics are existing within the tumor
type pharmacogenomics if there's certain
types of drugs that would be better
are metabolized differently for
different individuals and on different
individuals and their compare disease
could be treated better with different
drugs so that's certainly a promising
area and looking at wellness planning
our place to question mark after that
because wellness planning is in some
ways controversial um partly because we
know that just based on family history
we know that we're at increased risk of
various things and um population level
some individuals are better than others
at making lifestyle changes that would
impact their and reduce potentially
their risk for various things though so
that's the reason for the question right
there we also know that um private
individuals can sometimes be interested
in in pursuing direct consumer so we've
seen that that take place as well and an
uptake of that so from a clinical
perspective the literature tends to
focus on on the points that here around
predictive capacity so there certainly
is concerned that the genotype-phenotype
correlation is not always one to want
it's not always direct there's often
multiple things to multi factors that
are at playing by them including
environmental things so there are some
genetic variations that we know if the
particular variation is found that it
will lead to a particular phenotypic
expression or physical expression in
that individual but for the most part
there's some variation around that that
we aren't entirely certain what
particular genotypes might lead to the
phenotypes with exact predictability we
also know that the knowledge base is
changing rapidly so as more people have
genetic results available and and looked
at we know that at times what looked to
be a predictive
gene variant or genetic variation may
later proved not to be terribly
predictive or vice versa so there is
some of that that gets talked about in
the literature the issue around informed
consent the challenge to our current
paradigm around the autonomous
decision-maker in front of you and that
a decision is made or that a consent
form is signed at one moment in time now
this isn't the only arena in which its
proposed that consent is an ongoing
process but I would propose that along
with others in the literature that there
is something a bit unique here
particularly around genetics because may
be possible that a revelation is made
about another genetic relatives health
status just based on the individual
who's decided to pursue testing
themselves and the return of results
around I incidental findings it's
extremely on time consuming to walk
through the types of findings that that
may be revealed and I think that there
are teams of people that are working
diligently I'm trying to find the best
model of informed consent for genome
sequencing going forward so I applaud
those efforts on this therapeutic
misconception possibility around the
research that's taking place that I've
mentioned previously where there's an
expectation of personal benefit on
participating in genome sequencing
research and then again the
identifiability of or the potential
identifiability of research participants
from an ethical perspective there are
the issues around privacy and to lead to
some concerns about discrimination now
we know that the Genetic Information
non-discrimination Act does protect from
from some of those areas of concern
particularly in the healthcare setting
it even in the healthcare setting there
are exceptions we will so for
individuals seeking health insurance or
organizations or companies that are
below 15 employees are exclude
as well as life and long term disability
long term care and disability insurance
are excluded there may be very
legitimate reasons for their exclusion
but these are some of the ethical issues
that are some of the exclusions to that
legislation with regard to the
incidental and secondary findings
there's issues around what actual means
to different people so actionable in the
traditional sense would be that there is
some sort of treatment or screening at
the very least that could have occurred
in order to reduce someone's risk for
various things or to create various
condition actionable to other
individuals might mean that they're able
to make different life decisions based
on some of the knowledge if they knew
that they reddening significantly
increased risk of perhaps an earlier
death hour on a condition that might
impact their cognitive ability they may
make different life decisions and for
them they think that being able to have
that bit of insight is an actionable is
something that they find beneficial
because of that action ability as well
be the uncertainty of the findings is is
a concern that's brought up quite a bit
around incidental and what do you do
with findings that are where there's an
uncertainty around them and whether
those findings should be reveal to
various individual is the impact of
those two nite findings particularly of
the uncertainty on the individuals of
some potential psychosocial impact both
on the person who's had the genetic
testing them as well as others who are
biologically or genetically related to
that individual on once you know
something you can't unknow it and so
there's talk about one right not to know
if they are at an increased risk some
people would want to know and other did
not and that may not be consistent
through various families in fact we know
that it's often not consistent based on
other
genetic testing previous that have shown
this in the past and there's the concept
of the right to be open the future so
when we're talking about children
there's the idea that perhaps a child
would be treated differently if they
were known to be at a previous possessed
additional vist to an adult onset
condition and the fact that they may
grow up to be the type of person who
wouldn't wanted to know that information
um in addition we've got the issue that
comes up around the potential
infrastructure inadequacies so at the
moment are our clinicians currently
ready to deal with people bringing their
genome sequencing to them and I think
lots of lots of suggestions have been
that that we're not entirely ready yet
and how best to prepare for that may not
be overly straightforward and that other
support networks and other ways of
managing patients maybe maybe need it so
there's some efforts going on around on
certainly looking at ways that people
can interact with their genome through
some of the direct consumer sites and
and measuring some of that so that may
be informative as we move forward so the
bulk of what I'm going to talk about
today or at least i'm going to put
suggestions forward really in this
concept we talk about these things often
these things these ethical issues as it
and the benefits as if they're sort of
equally wade across across the spectrum
well in fact we know that decision
making that the risk of that benefits
the values that are at stake for
different individuals and making
decisions that it's not a
one-size-fits-all that in fact people
are going to wait things differently
depending on what their personal
experience if the illness might be or on
those around them what their experience
of illness has been and so with with
some of that in mind I'm just going to
go through
on a few things and put forward some of
my ideas as to how people might be
motivated or looking at benefits and the
risks associated with genome sequencing
so when it comes to some of the
motivations if you've got a seemingly
healthy individual or at least one who
perceives themselves as healthy and they
don't think that they've got any kind of
chronic thing they don't tend to take
much in the way of medications or any of
those sort of things they might be
motivated to to look at potentially
genome sequencing for curiosity purposes
it might be that they've got a curiosity
around their ancestral origin but
they're not really that that concerned
or in some cases that interested in some
of the other genetic information that
they might find out or they're assuming
that there won't be much much much of
interest in their genome anyway because
they themselves feel quite healthy
however others might be hoping to
identify some actionable type genetic
predispositions so that whilst they're
healthy at the moment they would hope to
change or to ensure that they remain
that way by making some lifestyle
changes or increasing their screening
rates for various conditions because of
a known now increased risk for face
various conditions they might also want
to learn about other types of genetic
things like a carrier status so to know
that they themselves although they're
not having any problem with your very
condition they do have a genetic
variation that puts them or their family
at an increased risk or if they're
planning so around reproductive planning
that might be another reason or
motivation for doing some of the genetic
tests urgent genome sequencing and
others may not actually themselves want
that information but they are interested
perhaps even contributing to just
general scientific advancement and
they've read about the fact that the
the best way to improve information or
knowledge about the genome is to have
more people more people's genome data
combined in in public databases from a
risk perspective there are those issues
that I've already discussed around loss
of privacy intend to impact on
insurability impact on their info on
others and the others right not to know
about something fact there is still a
lot of uncertainty around many of the
many of the findings of the genome and
the potential psychic psychological
impact some people might think that
they'll cope quite well with finding out
that a significant increased risk for
some condition would turn out that they
actually don't like quite cope as well
as they thought they might so um so
those are some of the things that they
might be thinking about and those risks
might outweigh their general curiosity
or the other sorts of things because
they're in a general healthy on a
predisposition from I've put a child on
this picture as well because I think
some of these things when we talk about
children particularly as their firstborn
many children are presumed to be quite
healthy in that state and thankfully so
and and so it might the motivations that
parents have for these various for
genome sequencing at the young age there
of their child might be for these very
same reasons but I do think it raises
some different questions I'm not going
to go into great detail again because of
the fact that we're talking about we're
making an assumption around a seemingly
healthy child now next we'll just talk
about a person with a strong family
history of illness so some of the
motivation for someone in that case is
that we know that some people who
witnessed family members um we've gone
through serious illness they themselves
sometimes make assumptions that well
that's my genetic relative
they assume that they will in fact
follow the same course they assume that
they will die of heart disease as their
father did or perhaps assume that they
will get Alzheimer's as their family
member has as well so it might be that
they're motivated to go through this
because they think they've got this
uncertainty they're making assumptions
about things and they're hoping that it
may either reduce some of that in
uncertainty perhaps alleviate some of
their fears or in fact confirm some of
their views some people feel better
knowing the answer than then not knowing
an answer so when it comes to some of
the risks I think privacy is still
certainly a risk but others may make
assumptions already regarding that
person's risk so it might be that that
others are making assumptions that
someone's at an increased risk of heart
disease because they know that their
family members are at risk of that the
same goes for ensure ability we know
that family history is typically the way
that that people look at at shoreham to
be looking at some of the insurance
rates that that individuals will have be
influenced by their family history of
the illness um we also know that family
history of course is utilized by our
health professionals to try and provide
some insight into the increased risk of
some people may be of various types of
conditions that they could do something
on lifestyle changes around the
secondary findings are still at issue
for someone with a strong family history
of illness of course it's perhaps the
strongest one that might outweigh the
fact that they want to provide some
uncertainty or provide some excuse me
some information that might alleviate
some of the uncertainty those secondary
findings might be that they're assuming
that everything other than things are
currently worried about are fine and
find out actually if there are some
other previous positional things and
that psychological impact of learning
about some of those may be significant
for various people we know that
different personalities are people are
information seekers in which case the
more they learn the less anxious they
become even if some of that information
would in itself be potentially anxiety
provoking there are others that the more
information they could have and the more
uncertainty they're dealing with the
more anxious they become so again we're
dealing with the fact that there are
going to be spectrums of people and the
way they handle this information is is
going to be different and again the
impact on others as well but that may
not want to know in the family so a
person who's experienced a chronic
illness how they themselves have already
experienced it has have stomach illness
experience and so on it may be that
they're hoping for what they're waiting
most heavily is the potential for
pharmacogenomics to give them some
better indication of medications that
they can utilize or different tailored
treatment options hope for a cure even
with there being more knowledge about
the disease that they are battling with
now when it comes to the risks we're in
the same situation where they're very
similar to the lot to the previous in
fact the waiting's may be significantly
more towards the benefit because they
themselves are in a situation of a
chronic illness and that might be so
burdensome to them that they're willing
to take on some of those other risks
that they see as potential risk as
opposed to the actual experience they're
currently going through so um next I'll
talk about a person who's been diagnosed
with a life-threatening condition so it
might be that the person previously had
previously I've seen themselves
as someone who was quite healthy and
didn't have it in issue and then they're
diagnosed with cancer and so in some
cases it may be that that cancer
diagnosis means that all bets are sort
of off when it comes to some of the risk
that what is most important what is most
salient to them at this moment is
learning as much as they can about
treatment options and the way that
they're that the tumor might respond to
different medications and and that their
perspective is completely changed by
this diagnosis we saw this in some ways
with embryonic stem cell research
whereby individuals who might help quite
strongly to the weather that type of
research or treatment pathway was was
something that was a viable one from an
ethical standpoint to when they had a
family member of themselves diagnosed
with a condition that may have been may
have seen some benefit from that type of
research or someone with a spinal cord
injury there was some shift in whether
they found that to be ethically
acceptable or not um and next time i'm
going to talk it from a similar
perspective around um a life-threatening
illness of a sick child or a chronic
illness of a sick talent being a parent
in that case so we know that some of
these things can be quite quite
transformative for people so in a study
that I was involved in previously with
colleagues at the University of Sydney
we looked at an ethically contentious
topic around the use of pre-implantation
genetic diagnosis for an actual a match
sibling or savior sibling in this
context it may be that are in this this
context what we did was discussed with
both the professionals and parents that
were in the midst of conversations or
may have been in a situation of having
the conversations about this
and treatment option um as to what they
thought about the clinical and the
ethical implications of that and from
the professional standpoint intended not
to talk about this as a as something for
parents to consider mostly given the the
types of ethical arguments that were put
forward in the literature around
commodification of children and children
experiencing risks without personal
benefit themselves interestingly though
the parents consistently reported von
wanting to know about therapeutic
options and overwhelmingly dismissing
some of those arguments that were so
prevalent in the literature and were
repeated by some of the clinicians and
against whether or not a parents should
have another child under these types of
circumstances and in fact some of the
parents talked about the fact that they
might worry about those things that I
not in the situation are having had the
experience of potentially losing their
child they didn't have the luxury of
considering on some of those other
things that may be the same case when it
comes to genome sequencing where they
might if they are in a position not in a
position where the child is currently at
risk of serious health condition or or
death they might be interested in
discussing some of those other ethical
issues but in the primary one what
they're interested in are some of the
genetic line isn't so they're waiting
towards the benefit of genome sequencing
I think is quite understandable and and
not overly surprising from a
philosophical lens maybe some of the
things that may be driving this hour
around formative experience so that the
fact they've had the formative
experience of individuals having a
forward to the end and the illness
themselves or in within their child the
idea around regret theory whereas
they've tried everything they've looked
at all avenues
to try and treat or understand a
condition that there are more things
going on than just the individuals of
idea around relational economy and the
fact that there are changing
perspectives that go on so even with
clinicians in the study that I was
talking about their perspectives tended
to change when they were talking from a
professional standpoint supposed to
speaking from a standpoint of a parent
so when they started talking about what
their expectations and what their
thoughts were around treatment options
for their own child there tend to be a
shifting in position and it showed
really some intuitive decision-making as
opposed to some of the analytic
decision-making that we've seen
previously and I'm driving some of this
was the moral valorisation or what I've
suggested in my life colleagues
suggested with a moral valorisation of
children provide that the survival of
that child was good above some of the
other what um were praised by some of
the participants in my study as kind of
the academic or the ivory tower
discussions um but that was fine to
discuss in those academic settings but
from their real-world perspective they
were things that helped far less weight
in their decision-making now the value
of the empirical in this type of context
is that we saw in literature lots of
ethical arguments that are lots of
ethical concerns being raised and while
those concerns may be quite valid and I
wouldn't argue otherwise I do think
there's a value in utilizing empirical
from those on the front lines from those
who are in the midst of the decision
making and the usefulness of that it
that it could provide a really a
description of those opinions and
reasoning patterns that are influencing
decision-making and that can help inform
some of the consent process that's going
on the Jenner the the data that's
generated may challenge the current
convention
of the way that we review the ethical
concerns that are being forward in the
context of genome sequencing it may be
that quite a few people are okay with
the risk involved in the potential loss
of privacy and and so from that
perspective would be willing to to take
on those risks with the potential for
there to be the benefit that they see is
as far more relevant and it made may
show this shift in position that hadn't
been evident previously so what I'm what
I'm suggesting is that perspective
matters and I don't think that I'll be
the first to say this I but I think that
it's a good reminder in the case of
genome sequencing that while there are
risks and there are potential benefits
and motivations for people wanting to
pursue this it's not going to be the
same for everyone and that there are
some very powerful on drivers behind
whether or not somebody may decide to
take up on genome sequencing and what
information they want returned to them
in that context so empirical bioethics
really can reveal some of these stark
contrast between what we discuss in our
academic world and what the patients and
families and clinicians are
contemplating in there what alcohol
real-world perspective also may reveal
some some real differences between
scientific and medical research and the
way that patients and families
experienced medicine overall and between
decision-making in the abstract so when
I'm sitting and I'm thinking about the
waves of the wrist and the ethical
concerns that might be generated by
particular emerging technology that may
be vastly different in the
decision-making context for those that
are dealing with on life threatening and
the illness experience perspectives
again I'm not suggesting that that's
entirely new but I'm putting this
forward as a reminder
for us to think about this in the
context of genome sequencing I would
also like to say that I'm not suggesting
that the univ he recalled can tell us
how we ought to behave but instead i
think that empirical data can provide
some guidance in and inform the ways
that we ought to move forward with
various things because they do take on
the perspectives of those and they can
sometimes shape the communities from
which those ought type statements are
being generated so I put forward this
question what is on on your radar I
would suggest that a lot of things
become relevant when they're on when
they become part of your radar so I'm
using this as an example we've got a lot
of things coming at Isola and you slowly
filter and we don't think about may not
have on our radar things such as child
with leukemia until we have a neighbor
child who's diagnosed or until we have a
better a child of our own diagnosed or
we ourselves are somehow directly
impacted somehow a particular technology
or treatment option or or medication
becomes part of your radar part of your
reality and that in itself might change
the way that you think about that topic
for that if it's a controversial
treatment on whether or not you'd be
willing to engage with that I think in
the abstract you're not always terribly
accurate in trying to predict how we
behave when a situation presents itself
so I oppose these sorts of questions of
course not expecting anyone to enter me
on this but when when people pose these
questions I would suggest that that we
think about whether or not there are
limits on the information that someone
would want to know that you would want
to know or that you would want others to
know about you so are the things that
you would want to learn if you said yes
regarding
your genome sequence where you wouldn't
want that shared with others and you
want to really control how that
information was shared with others and
then from the perspective if you have
children would you want you your child's
complete genome sequenced and if so the
same sorts of questions what information
would you want to know do you think
there are particular things that should
be that should not be revealed based on
the fact that that it's a child's genome
that's being tested and there that's
being sequence and again what you want
others to know about that child's genome
sequencing so what I'm suggesting here
is that we're not not everything is on
polar opposites so just because we've
got somebody who is a real enthusiast of
new technologies doesn't mean that that
they're going to take up every
technology just because it exists so
it's a cartoon I like to be on the one
spectrum and neither is it from the
other perspective where someone who
thinks that genome sequencing is is a
step too far that it's too early to be
doing these sorts of things it's not
necessarily that they are someone who
dismisses or is not interested in any
technology but it might be that there's
some place along the way that they
haven't reached yet or questions that
haven't been answered yet but they feel
need to be answering so with that in
mind I'm coming to the part of my talk
where hopefully there'll be some
questions are some points of discussion
not like able to be had again I'm I'm
with the primer in genomics and ethics
and these are some of my colleagues that
I'm working with currently and we're
trying to take up the question the
empirical question in particular of some
of these some of these issues how people
are managing on the kind of difficult
consent process as opposed to on the one
time off and looking at to return of
incidental findings and attitudes
towards that
um we got funding are currently receive
funding from the events in a healthy
lillis concen research and education
fund to really fill the gap between
those the clinical practice and some of
the ethical legal and social
implications of genomic sequencing and
we work closely with our clinical and
and lab colleagues in trying to to look
through some of these questions our
department has expertise in multiple
areas though that you can see around the
TLC issues philosophy and careful
bioethics communication on the community
engagement which is something that I
think is going to be vital in ensuring
that various communities have a voice in
policy decisions as they move forward as
we move forward in decisions around
genome sequencing return of results on
policy perhaps some further legislation
or maybe we've gone far enough with some
of that that will be decision yep I'm
maybe that's enough there we go there we
go do we have a question sorry you've
just come through the online sorry about
that um so did you write all of going
here if anyone has any any questions um
I I would appreciate any coming through
looks like there are none at the moment
I apologize for that town let's break in
there so I think if I don't have any
questions that are coming through I may
just leave everyone on with some some
thoughts really around
around potential avenues for exploration
I think that research with various
communities I'll reiterate that is
something that is is going to be vital
going forward understanding the
experience of the early uptake people
who have begun the early uptake of
genome sequencing and I think there's a
lot that can be gained from learning how
they've responded and how they've dealt
with some of the return of results in
particular and their decision making
process I think there are things to be
learned from those families that have
gone through the clinical Odyssey
diagnostic Odyssey so there is going to
be a believes in that and as well as
those who want to move forward in
various arenas but may not themselves be
interested in return of the results at
this time so going to want to ensure
that that we've gained a variety of
perspectives in going forward with this
to ensure that the promise of genome
sequencing is really felt by by those as
many as possible so from there um I may
go ahead and just remind you of the
continuing education credits as you can
see there's a link if you are looking to
obtain those credits
so I've come to be the end of my talk
here thank you